he's a nut I mean he's he's a deep deep
nut on a one-on-one level I I like him
you know my tolerance for crazy people
is I think is high a tolerance as you're
ever gonna find I love being around
David Allan Coe I would have loved to
hang out with Tiny Tim I can listen to
Sun Raw on a tape recording grant I have
it's not patience it's love for people
who are live outside the law and Glenn
Beck is that I mean I compared Glenn
Beck mostly to Abbie Hoffman you know
when I was a child I would read
Woodstock Nation and steal this book and
I didn't really agree with very much of
any of it because it was essentially
socialist and collectivist and didn't
really ring true for me but I loved the
way he did it I loved the outrageous
poetry of it and I loved that
my arguments with my dad about it where
my dad thought he was a dangerous nut
and I thought he was a fun nut and my
arguments about Glenn Beck are exactly
the same as he's to have with my dad
about Abbie Hoffman I'm so upset that
someone else compared him to Abbie
Hoffman publicly before I Diggs I've
been telling all my friends liberals do
misunderstand it they liberals think the
medium is the message and I believe the
message is the message and I had Tommy
smothers tear me apart for going on
Glenn Beck and he was right Tommy
smothers was a hundred percent right he
said that by going on I gave some
credence and support to some very bad
ideas I think it's exactly right Tommy
smothers is a hero of mine I think he's
completely right to bust me on that and
I think I'm also completely right to say
but you should go on shows you don't
agree and tell the truth is you see it I
think that's also completely right he
said to me does not say to me this on
air but he said to me
off-air if Hitler had a talk show you
would go on it and I answered yes and I
tried to tell the truth and I think
that's you know when I went on glenn
beck i argue them a gay rights
I argue about Mormonism I agree with
Glenn Beck on a few things those are the
things I talked about when I went on the
show I went on in order to argue but it
is misunderstood and I think that I mean
my appearance is misunderstood that
wasn't your question the question was
his he misunderstood there's something I
see done with Howard Stern
I want a Howard Stern have done dozens
and dozens maybe hundreds of hours on
Howard Stern I'm not a big Howard Stern
listener but if you listen to Howard
Stern every day you develop a deep
context for who Howard Stern is what's
important to him what's important to
Robin what his morality is what his
relationships are what his heart is and
I'm not talking about listening for a
week I'm talking about listening to
Howard Stern for months and I'm not
talking about you know a dozen hours
over a month I'm doing about hundreds of
hours you know you get to know Howard
Stern and when he says something it's
automatically in a very deep and very
big context and when someone who hates
Howard Stern there are plenty of them
pull something out of context even if
you get the context either they play you
fifteen minutes before and after you're
really missing the context and I think I
don't listen to glenn beck very much so
I don't know but I think with someone
like glenn beck if you listen everyday
you understand that the rage is also
tempered the outrageous things are
tempered with a certain kind of humanity
and certain kinds of other that i
disagree with them on a lot of things
but i'm just saying that there's a full
person there and I think what we often
forget when we're reading media you know
you pick up the paper and read oh this
is what Obama said it that you forget
that there is not the context of the
quote but the context of the
public figure and I think that with
Abbie Hoffman when you'd read something
about revolution in the violent
overthrow of the United States
government unless you'd seen all the
pranks and the playfulness and the fun
and the sexiness all kind of rolled in
you couldn't possibly understand that
now you're also not supposed to because
these are all grown-ups and they Howard
Stern knows he'll be taken out of
context Abbie Hoffman knew that Glenn
Beck knew that so they do have a
responsibility but for me once you
listen to somebody a lot on radio or on
TV you develop a relationship with them
that's not entirely different from I got
this crackpot uncle and he said this
thing about how guns should be carried
by deer so that they can defend
themselves and you kind of laugh about
it and everybody you're talking to knows
that crazy uncle and they know what he
does at Christmastime you know and they
know that if Thanksgiving he was dancing
in a hula skirt if he'd know all this
and they also know that when their car
broke down at 3:00 in the morning that
was the uncle that showed up you know
they know all those things and I think
that with public figures they're not
supposed to be given that much leeway
but I still do you know I still read
something Howard Stern said and even if
it's directly contrary to something I
believed I never think well Howard's
evil you know because I know he's not
evil I know he's a good guy and even
when Glenn Beck says stuff that's
reprehensible I say well I sat in a room
with Glenn he's not he's not trying to
kill people he's not hurting children
he's just thank him and sometimes he's
thinking half-assed so yeah I do think
he's sometimes taken out of context but
I think that's also part of his job and
it's okay